Hollywood couples step out in LA with  their love on full display I'm just so  very very lucky  first up Lady Gaga celebrates her 31st  birthday on Tuesday with her new beau by  her side Mother Monster was spotted  hand-in-hand with her boyfriend  Christian Kirino in upscale  attire as the couple stepped out for her  star-studded beat a dinner at a Venice  Beach restaurant with her closest  friends meanwhile Sarah Paulson and  girlfriend Holland Taylor take a  shopping trip following the outing the  pair enjoyed a romantic stroll together  where the 42 year old Feud star sported  chic sunglasses and a grey sweatshirt  that red radical love I'm having fun  living my life that's for sure  you